in the book doom the politics of
catastrophe
your newest book you describe wars
pandemics and the terrible disasters in
human history
which stands out to you as the worst in
terms of how much
it shook the world and the human spirit
i am glad
i was not around
in the mid 14th century when the bubonic
plague swept across eurasia
as far as we can see
that was history's worst pandemic
maybe there was a comparably bad one in
the
reign of the emperor uh justinian but
there's some reason to think it wasn't
as bad
and the more we learn about
uh
the 14th century with the more we
realized that it really was across
eurasia and the the mortality was
in some places 50
in some places higher there were whole
towns that were just emptied
and when one reads about the black death
it's an unimaginable
nightmare
of of
death and
madness in the death with flagellate
orders
wandering from town to town
seeking to ward off divine retribution
by flogging themselves
people turning on the local jewish
communities as if it's somehow their
fault that must have been a nightmarish
time
if you ask me
for an an also ran a runner-up it would
be
it would be world war ii uh in eastern
europe
and in many ways
it might have been worse because
for a medieval
peasant the sense of being on the wrong
side of divine retribution must have
been overpowering
in the mid 20th century
you knew
that this was man-made
murder
on a massive industrial scale
if one lee if one reads grossman's life
and fate
just to take one example
one enters a
a hellscape
that it's extremely hard
to imagine oneself in
so these are two of the great disasters
of of human history and
if we did have a time machine if one
really were able to transport people
back and
and give them a glimpse of these times
i think the post-traumatic stress would
be enormous people would come back from
those those trips even if it was a
one-day excursion with guaranteed
survival uh in a state of of utter shock
you